as far as travel goes for 2023 travel
expert Sarah Danish shows us more
2023 is shaping up to be another big
travel year as people continue to place
more emphasis on experiences over things
we're seeing more Americans constantly
booking in advance planning trips three
four even six months ahead so if you're
looking for inspiration on where to
travel and stay in 2023 here are a few
places to consider Halifax Canada I know
unexpected but great for so many reasons
there's the Waterfront Boardwalk Halifax
Public Gardens and The Maritime Museum
of the Atlantic and just explore in the
center of downtown in the new Queens
Marquis District you've got Mir and
Autograph Collection hotel which offers
this refined yet uniquely local
experience polished rooms with wood
interiors and something cool they even
have their own art gallery and direct
access to the water you can rent Kayaks
paddle boards and bicycles or go out on
one of their two yeah two boats reach
and little wing but if warm weather and
palm trees are calling your name let's
face it a tropical vacation is always a
good idea head to Waikiki in Hawaii from
snorkeling to hiking Diamondhead to even
catching a hula show there's plenty to
do on the island opt for a place where
you don't have to choose between the
beach or the pool because both are
perfect at the Sheraton Waikiki they
have the family-friendly hellamoa
playground pool which has slides
fountains pretty much like a water park
right on site and it's fun for all ages
and then they also have the edge
infinity pool for guest 16 and older
which is totally Instagram worthy as
they like to say and it's a pretty
obvious reason why this was voted the
number one best pool in the nation per
USA Today
alternatively go luxury and head to
Miami Beach of course we know the dining
and nightlife scene is huge in South
Florida the Saint Regis Bell Harbor is
the epitome of Oceanfront luxury and has
yet again been awarded the Famous Five
Star five Diamond rating for 2022. with
27 stories overlooking the white sandy
beaches of Miami it literally sits at
the intersection of art fashion and
design you can pamper yourself with
their award-winning Spa dining one of
their many incredible restaurants and
its location is pretty ideal too just
steps away from the shops of the Miami
Beach Enclave a lot of elements make
this the ultimate luxury retreat in a
very vibrant City so of course as you
plan ahead for the year I will leave you
with three final tips on how to make the
most out of your travel dollars number
one book direct from Airlines to hotels
this is always the best way for the best
deals and the most flexibility number
two look to the bigger brands for Flash
sales and seasonal deals there's always
options out there and number three my
final tip get a trip on the books it's
been proven that having a vacation plan
actually makes people happier as they
know that they have something to look
forward to so plan a trip and get
excited for all the memories that you're
about to make in 2020